you know and even like maybe getting
women out of the media but I know a
little hypocritical I know guys but at
least two women I know I know I know
this drives me freaking nuts
villainization of any male role model
yes yes like of course men aren't doing
well if they've got no kind of road map
for how they're supposed to be and
literally anything they do is vilified
and told that they're wrong like no
wonder men are in trouble and they're
feeling how they are
that's funny I think they're hilarious
the next out guys what up guys welcome
to the just pearly things YouTube
channel and welcome to my reaction
series before I start don't forget to
subscribe to the channel and ring that
notification Bell the way you're gonna
be notified of my daily videos like the
video on your way and guys let's get to
2 000 likes on this video okay that's
the most important metric that YouTube
uses to push out these streams anyways
um welcome to the show Christine hello I
have a special guest she's our newest
Talent at the audacity Network guys she
does these great essay videos where she
breaks down why the world is so nutty
today
attempts to break down make sure make
sure you go subscribe to her Channel
because we're trying to get her to a
thousand subscribers so make sure you go
subscribe right now the link to that is
in the description so we were just
talking you don't know what make tau is
no I thought it was a person no I have a
kind of idea but I'm really not sure
what do you think it is I think it's to
do with like red pill
um I think I've briefly read somewhere
it's like a movement of men who are
I don't know if it's got anything to do
with like passport Bros that's about the
extent of my knowledge so it's men going
their own way men going there so either
there's different levels some are
walking away from Marriage altogether
they basically looked at the institution
and the way Society set up and say we
are discriminated against we cannot
interact with a woman without there
being a legal consequence right even if
they talk to us now they're thinking
about passing laws for staring
this is how crazy it's getting yes yes
yes so some of them say okay I will have
women sexually but I won't go further
than that some are like I don't want to
say ins they're like choosing the incel
life they're like I won't even deal with
them right some got wrecked in a divorce
and are saying they are walking away
from divorce so it kind of depends what
level some won't even talk to women
some some will talk to us and sleep with
us but after that they say we're done so
will live and have a long-term
relationship but will not do marriage
okay I think those those laws about
staring is really just a discrimination
against ugly men oh of course because if
it's an attractive guy then you
know say anything because
they are longer yeah
it's like in the gyms all those guys are
getting oh a gym Crete what's the
difference between a creep he's even
good looking or he's not well and the
girls will be dressed like and then
they're like why did he look well you
kind of look like
you know it's like they do that thing
where they tuck their shirt in at the
back it's like why are you doing that
you're just like why why do you need to
do also doesn't it make you sweat more
because it's tucked into you well they
could they could wear some sweats yeah
or some like longer basketball shorts if
they really they will wear oversized
t-shirts but they will specifically tuck
the back into their crop tops
I've seen this that is so true and
there's no other reason for it other
than to show you're behind because what
what other benefits does that have it's
either Tucker on talk like why do you
only untuck in the back
right
here pull up the video all right so this
is a mgtow channel it's called Sandman
so looks don't matter is the biggest lie
women tell men
hi everyone same man here this video was
brought to you by a donation from Jeff
and he didn't give me a topic so I
wanted to discuss a topic I recently
found on the men's rights Reddit about
how apparently when women say looks
don't matter it's a great big lie women
tell men funny enough it's both true and
false depending on a bunch of different
things usually a topic like this one is
found on a black pill Forum but since
those are pretty much shut down these
days it seems that they've started
posting on them mrm subreddit instead
most black pillars these days are in
their late teens and early 20s so from
their perspective it is true that for
women up to the age of 25 and under
looks are the most important thing then
later on the First wall around 25 to 26
many women start looking to lock down on
me and if they're smarts that's pretty
much what happened with Jason Statham
he's 55 and his fiance of 14 years is
36. her name is Rosie Huntington widely
and he probably waited to make sure that
she wasn't a gold digger and he had kids
with her first before the marriage he
doesn't exactly have grade looks but he
does have wealth status even though he's
only five foot nine also even if they
get married there's still plenty of time
for her to get divorced and ride the
chat horse plus he also gives off a bad
boy Vibe so that could be another reason
she's attracted to him I'm not sure if
he was vetting her the whole time or if
he just made a big mistake getting
engaged but the black pill Community has
been freaking out trying to figure out
why she would be with someone shorter
and with the face of a crow magnet man
she's like one of those women Leonardo
DiCaprio dates because she too was a
model when they started dating when she
was only 23. his status in the movie
business probably helped her land roles
in the Transformers film as well as Mad
Max Fury Road a number of years later
there was a good chance that she was
just using him to advance her career
first maybe he's drawing out their
13-year relationship and getting married
after a long time so that the kids get
old enough where if they do divorce he
doesn't have to pay any child supports I
don't know after all marriage is nothing
more than betting half your assets these
days that she'll love you forever you
can sure bet that she was probably
riding the rooster roller coaster
choo-choo train before she ever met him
I just think that the black pillars need
to understand that just because looks
don't matter with this guy he's the
exception and not the rule also when a
woman genuinely says to you that looks
don't matter to her that usually means
you have a car a house and lots of money
that's funny I think they're hilarious
the Big Town guy I think they're so
funny
yeah what do you think do you think
looks matter I think it's so difficult
um because
personally values are really important
but I would be a liar if I sat here and
said that looks don't matter at all I
think to some people they can mean
different things but I think for the
majority of women just looking at the
current trends when they say looks don't
matter I have to agree with him I do
think it's probably because the guy has
something else somewhere else yeah and I
think sometimes we'll think like well
like I rejected that guy who was good
looking because he was an idiot or
whatever it was but it's like okay you
still you still don't like ugly men yeah
and that's the thing like girls on my
show will be like no I don't I don't
care about looks and I'll be like my
last boyfriend was ugly and I always say
pull up a picture I want to see he's
never up they're never ugly no I mean
he's always decent looking I've never
had a guy where I'm like oh he's ugly
yeah yeah I've only I've only had one
guy that I thought was a lot lower than
the girl do you know what I mean like
most of them were kind of a look smart
yeah yeah you have other things that
make up for for your lack of looks let's
also not forget status as well as
resources status is important because
she you know I a lot of women say looks
don't matter
because okay let's let's assume she's
dating like a six or five in the guy in
reality he she thinks she's a 10. so
that's why she thinks looks don't matter
but in reality she's probably like a
four she thinks she's stepping ah
because she's been sleeping with the top
man so she thinks Luke doesn't matter
because in her mind she looks way better
than the guy ah
those are always over inflated yeah your
status down the road it also is
representative intelligence to be
incredibly successful but we all know
the looks matter because of the Golden
Ratio or golden mean and it's Universal
in everyone Beauty matters because of
math a symmetrical face is more pleasing
to look at because it's properly
proportionate a phase triggers the
automatic response of either attraction
or repulsion so it's a lie that they
tell to Beta box even if a guy looks
like Statham and they're with them for
10 plus years and have kids with them
it's just a lie I'll discuss more in a
moments anyways now back to someone
should post pictures of older guys with
money that look average or below average
and hot guys with no money to see which
ones women prefer to message on Tinder
clown world show but we know the answer
to that looks matter more than ever
because most people don't have the time
to read dating profiles and instead just
swipe left or right there's also the
fact that biology matters besides just
Aesthetics the taller and better looking
the children a woman has the more likely
the woman can use her son for survival
if something bad happens wow I never
thought about that huh I never thought
about that as being an incentive for
like jeans huh over resources if
something happens to the father if the
father gets killed or like King said
someone comes in and slits his throat
the sun would then become the kind of
head yeah and if you have daughters the
sun's then going to be more likely to be
able to protect your daughters as well
if you've picked a guy that has got
better genes
didn't even think of that to the top
three percentage of attractive meals
then other women also have to be nicer
to her the mother because if they don't
then they might get on her bad side who
do you think would have more options a
top five percent looks guys with no
money or a top five percent money guy
with no looks
five percent money guy I don't know I
disagree I I think I think money because
authority of women are gonna go after
that because they
want what comes with it but yeah I
disagree with that because
um
anyone it's not that hard to make women
think you have money
right
but it's definitely very hard to make
women think you're you're attractive
right okay
what if the women knew they knew like
how much each made if they knew how much
each made yeah so like top five percent
looks I think looks will still win in
today's society because women don't
really need men
oh
that's true actually I think they did an
experiment and the chick picked the
teacher over the software engineer the
hot teacher I'm like pretty sure
I don't really have an opinion either
way I was just thinking about it and
then the man's mother turns against them
pretty quickly those are just
instinctive evolutionary behaviors a
woman saying that looks don't matter is
like a man saying that her number of
Partners doesn't matter or that her
fertility doesn't matter many women also
say that looks don't matter to give men
false hope so they can more easily be
put in the friend zone and his attention
can be extracted for emotional tampon
Services if women pretty much told men
the truth it looks and also I actually
think I mean I I I sent I I made this
point before but I don't know if you if
you actually thought about what I said I
actually think
um genes are more valuable than
resources
because no matter how much resources you
have you can't you can't really do
anything about your jeans if your genes
are trash you don't think that resources
comes with good genes because there's
like intellect like IQ I think is
inheritable
yes and no because today we live in a
world where IQ doesn't necessarily
equate to like financial success anymore
yes it has not all the time no it does
yeah it's like that's like there's two
there's two predictors of success the
number one is IQ the second the second
is understand that but the problem is
the market is now flooded so it's not
like it's only the people with IQ that
have more resources anymore so either
ways resources is not necessarily
directly tied to no I think it's mostly
IQ
with resources like social media has a
lot of resources yeah but like we live
in a bubble that most people aren't
YouTubers you know what I mean like this
is a very Niche part of the world you
don't like like I think sometimes we
think it's like a different reality
because we're just around so many
YouTubers with money but it's really not
a large percentage of people yeah but
like we said like I still I still stick
to my point because in reality in this
part of the world most women live on on
social media yeah so most women don't
even know what what real what the real
things to look for in men
yeah okay good point that's a good point
did matter it would discourage many men
and make them start to hate women so how
many women do you think get in
relationships for their brand
I was thinking about this like I I feel
like there's I think majority of women
yeah Society like not because they want
the man but they want the Instagram
wedding pose
yes
it's not about who he is it's like the
the post I don't even know apart from
the post I think there even a lot of
women that that get into relationships
because it will further their own
um ambitions
or how they're viewed by their peers I
think a lot of girls will get with guys
because like at the time he's deemed
like the cool guy and like oh yeah and
we care so much what other people think
about us women will say stupid things
like I'm sure the right girl is out
there waiting for you and there's always
someone out there for everyone basically
saying I don't want you and probably no
one else but I can't tell you that or
you might take it out on me a guy hears
nonsense like that enough times he
starts to believe it that hope might
keep him dating and looking for romance
for 10 to 20 years long enough to get
some woman pregnant to divorce Graves
him and ruins his life for women they
don't care that the old guys check out
of the dating markets they want the
young guys to keep trying because then
it means that they won't hate women and
they might get hitched and not figure
out women until it's just too late
that's the thing that most guys don't
understand at some point in life be it
in their 40s or 50s or 60s they will
lose interest in women and when that
happens they'll cut off the attention
they give them women need to keep the
male effort flowing as long as possible
and that's one of the main reasons they
lie and tell you that looks don't matter
not to mention that if looks don't
matter and they convince you that money
and Status matter more you
I wonder if women
it would be really interesting if they
had a chart of women
based on how hot they are right and like
the symmetry of their face Maybe measure
waisted hip to waist ratio whatever and
measure
um how many kids they have it'd be
interesting to see if hotter chicks have
more children or not or if they ruin
their like if they ruin it because I was
just thinking about this chick's like 36
and maybe she has one or two kids
granted most people don't have kids but
it would just be or don't most women
don't have a lot of kids but it would
just be interesting to see if the hotter
women end up passing on more jeans
because I'd imagine the more symmetrical
the face like the better genes they're
passing so it's like I just wonder if
hotter chicks pass on more genes or if
now the uglier chicks are doing it more
because I'd imagine like the curse of
being an eight to ten is that you have
access to the most high status guys and
like you can't choose like how do you
pick right like when we have too many
choices it's harder for us to pick yeah
to make a choice yeah so like they like
a lot I've heard a lot of guys say that
like the eights to ten like older guys
will say the eights to tens end up like
never getting married or whatever
because they can't decide correct and
it's like almost a curse now I don't
know if that's true or not I've just
heard people say that but I would be
really curious to see if like what looks
have the most kids like on a one to ten
scale
I don't know I really you know I mean I
I'm just curious I think Beauty like
extreme Beauty for a woman is the same
curse as extreme wealth for a young boy
oh that you can both make or break you
like you become a trump or a job or a
hunter Biden
or you could just like ruin your life
now that's what I mean hunter Biden yeah
yeah he he ruins his life for like Trump
was a millionaire son he became a
billionaire for those things to a woman
you make a better plow horse if you
think that you're in so looking face
with a tiny chin and flat head doesn't
actually matter but they do women
imagine what types of children they're
gonna have with you and if they're kids
that look like they were beaten with an
ugly stick then they're less likely to
want you but if you were tens or
hundreds of millions of dollars then
they don't need to worry about their
sons being super good looking to take
care of them as the son husband in their
old age instead they don't have to worry
about that the abundance of resources
oftentimes stacked in favor of the
wealthy successful male I think it comes
down to the priorities that women feel
they have to pick which one is
ultimately more important a man's
appearance or his lifestyle some women
choose lifestyle so the ugly man that
provides it isn't a priority or so they
think and meanwhile they look for
another guy on the side basically gold
digging while going going behind his
back for somebody better others will
choose the loser guy that they're
attracted to I remember watching a video
a few weeks ago with a person talking
and it was discussing how people will
usually ignore what they want in a
partner looks wise when they tell other
people what they want but who they tell
you they want to be with and who they
actually end up with are usually
completely different it usually all
comes down to attraction and my first
long-term relationship at five years I
told myself that looks weren't as
important as compatibility and being
with the person that treated with
respect that I could build a future with
so I found such a person and I was
getting constant attention headaches
from being with her so the next time you
want to sleep with your wife or
girlfriend and she tells you that she
has a headache there's a good chance she
gets it from being with you mind you for
me while having sex the headaches would
actually go away so for me sex was my
only Escape then after her I picked a
partner that wasn't what I wanted on
paper but looks wise I was happy with
the tension headaches went away looks
matter to any woman that tells you that
they don't is lying to you and there's a
good chance to herself as well many
people are willing to throw away their
Futures to be with a good looking person
that's horrible for them I know that I
was certainly ready for that if you're
still going to date as a purple pill man
and get involved with women then you
better make sure there's a right amount
of chemistry there you will also know
that a woman is bargaining with herself
when she's trying to fix your appearance
and get you to dress a certain way I
know that in that five-year relationship
with my girlfriend put on makeup and
wore feminine things my headaches went
away but she only did that two or three
times in five years and when I asked her
for it again she got combative funny
thing is if she did all those things
that I asked I would have stayed with
her and married her and he and her
selfishness drove me away from her I
also dated a woman that had a nose job
and she looked like a slightly
overweight Marina bakarin she showed me
pictures before the nose job and she was
clearly unattractive back then even ugly
so people that are unattractive if they
really want relationship experience need
to work on their appearance and figure
out how to become more attractive to the
opposite sex men more so than women it's
also tough pill to swallow that people
are attracted to you for you on the
inside but you on the outside I know
what a shock LOL but guys want to
believe that fairy tale because we are
desperate to be validated for who we are
on the inside I think that many women
figure that out and that's why they
always say that looks don't matter to us
because it's playing on the fantasy that
men can be loved by women for who they
are inside instead of outside that we
can finally feel like we aren't alone in
this world that's the fantasy many women
have figured out and are playing up on
when it comes to us dudes anyways that's
it for today thanks again to Jeff for
the donation and I hope you enjoyed this
topic don't forget to smash the like
button the way that women won't smash
you if you're on what'd you what'd you
think
it's funny wasn't it yeah I mean he made
some good some good points I can't lie
I said was
true and based in reality I can't really
I think I think they're so funny they're
like I'm we're going we're all we're
going our own way we don't give
yeah like we are done yeah I mean fair
enough I can't really argue with the
logic to be honest
yeah I don't know just my feminine heart
is like oh don't give up you know yeah
you know logically I can't really blame
blame them yeah I mean I really hope
that like it inspires the laws to change
because I think a lot of things would be
fixed if they just didn't have this huge
system against them yeah where we're
just like you know and and even like
maybe getting women out of the media but
I know a little hypocritical I know guys
but at least two women I know I know I
know but but seriously like all the
chicks that like like I don't even it's
just the pandering in the music yeah I
just cannot stand it just drives me
freaking nut villainization of any male
role model yes yes like of course men
aren't doing well if they've got no kind
of road map for how they're supposed to
be and literally anything they do is
vilified and told that they're wrong
like no wonder men are in trouble and
they're feeling how they are and then
they get rid of like all the
um
strong men on TV in the media and take
the man out of the home it's like what
do we think is gonna happen yeah I have
a question if monetizing Beauty was a
minimum wage job how many women do you
think would do it monetizing Beauty was
a minimum wage job what do you mean like
I think I think that if you're married
like if you couldn't make millions of
monetizing beauty you could just make a
decent living
I think they would go get married
yeah because you still have to put in
the same amount of work you just be paid
like the same that they pay like people
that yeah am I being really stupid do
you mean like as in only fans like
Anyway modeling so that's the only way
that women could make money is that what
you mean no he's saying like like if
they pay only fans paid ten dollars an
hour oh there's no hope that you could
become oh yeah yeah I think women would
would get married I think they would
have better values I think they would
have more children yeah
I wish we could run an experiment to see
if this would but it would never happen
it would never happen no
um but guys let me know what you think
in the comments
um thank you for watching mgtow with me
today thanks for enlightening me
um guys make sure you go subscribe to
Christine's Channel she does really
great essay videos on today's debauchery
what's it called again the series
debunking The lunacy debunking the
lunacy that was a great name did you
come up with that that's a great idea
guys like the video on your way out
subscribe to the channel I'll talk to
you next time